law works because it's effectively
backed up by a state and that kind of
breaks down in space a little bit the
whole legality of who owns what is going
to fill volumes there are international
treaties that relate to space the UN
outer space treaty 1967 says space is
the common heritage of man and that
there can be no claims of national
sovereignty or appropriation but we also
have a bill that we put through Congress
to the President signed recently that
says open if you go to bars and you
establish a camp you can own them or you
mine metals there you can own those
metals well there's no international
agreement on that at all so who owns
those resources those are kind of gray
areas that will need to be developed
these are very very old rules the idea
of who owns what out in space you just
apply the same rules as as we have now
if I go out into international waters no
country owns that no territory owns that
there's no authority over it but if I
pull a fish out of the ocean it's my
fish but you can come up in your boat
and pull a fish out of the same spot of
the ocean that's your fish if you're a
commercial venture and you go out and
light an asteroid that's yours because
you went and got it but the people who
ultimately end up owning the territory
on Mars will not be countries on earth
it'll be the people who live there and
they're like we didn't sign that treaty
Mars is likely to be a lot like the Wild
West who is going to stop somebody if
there's a private company that wants to
go on the opposite side of Mars and they
want to just drill into the side of Mars
and see what they can find who's gonna
stop them no there's not gonna be
anybody to stop them
you're a homesteader on Mars and someone
comes and starts home standing in your
backyard no state is going to be able to
support your claim so it might have a
very you know kind of an old-school way
of dealing with that it was the same way
and
American West law enforcement was the
last thing to arrive rules were the last
thing to arrive justice was the last
thing to arrive Mars is likely to become
very much an unruly place